[Music]
I'm really excited for this session
because this is the one where we get to
talk to you guys about all of the
different ways and reasons that
customers are migrated in their hadoop
footprints into Google Cloud we are
gonna save some time at the end for
questions because we know this topic
gets a lot of those and a lot of unique
questions so please we are gonna run a
Dory out of app go ahead and pop them
the app and as you think of questions so
we go through put those in and we'll try
to get to as many as we can at the end
so I'm gonna hand off the Blake in a
little bit to tell you about how
customers are actually moving their
Hadoop footprints to GCP but before I do
that before you do that I'm going to
discuss a little bit of why they're
coming to Google cloud in the first
place for their Hadoop workloads so
there's a lot of benefits of migrating
hadoop to Google cloud first of all it's
pay for use so that's just like the rest
of the cloud you can start to map your
infrastructure to real usage
now usually that's a really great fit
for these Hadoop spark analytic
workloads where you have a lot of
variability you're also going to get
managed hardware and software so just
think about the task of keeping up with
all of the open source security patches
that are out there every week you know
that can be quite a daunting task and
something GC just one of the many things
GCP can help with you can also as you
move hadoop into the cloud you get to
keep the majority of your existing code
so usually there's only minimal changes
that are needed to run your on-prem
Hadoop and spark software on Google
Cloud you also get a lot of flexibility
so there's a lot of knobs that you can
turn in GCP and so most of those things
that you're gonna do to customize your
on-prem cluster you'll be able to do
that in Google cloud as well and finally
and this is the really big one is that
Google Cloud can really help you unlock
a lot of your HDFS data that might be
siloed in various clusters and hard to
tap into and I'll do a whole section on
that in a bit so Google Cloud we've been
trying to solve data problems for a long
time it started in
and for we came out with one of the
original MapReduce papers that got
turned a lot of those elements got put
into the original Apache Hadoop about a
year later we released a paper about
BigTable and that had a lot of personal
sudha basis and a lot of that got put
into HBase more recently and we've even
open sourced things with machine
learning code and tensorflow now about
ten years back we started to actually
take a lot of that infrastructure that
was built research papers things that
were battle tested on Gmail and maps and
we started to put those out as products
that any company regardless of if you're
a start-up in a garage or a large
enterprise could go use and start to use
the same technology that Google is using
and so we took all this knowledge from
research and open source and running our
own cloud platform going all the way
back to 2004 with that first MapReduce
paper we took that and we put it into
cloud data proc and if you're not
familiar with what that is that is
Google cloud platform fully managed
Apache spark and Apache Hadoop service
I'm saying Hadoop and spark but really
this is an engine for running lots of
open source software within that
ecosystem and we're gonna give you
things like customizable machine types
so let's say you have a batch of machine
learning jobs those can live on a
cluster that's got very compute
intensive specifications at the same
time you could have a lot of BI
applications and dashboards and
interactive sequel that's running on a
cluster that's a very memory heavy the
to never have to contend for resources
but both could still be reading and
writing from the same data set in cloud
C in cloud storage and we also offer a
lot of tools and features specifically
designed to help you with those kinds of
architectures as well as ephemeral
Hadoop and spark architectures in
general we're also going to try to give
you tight integration back to the rest
of Google cloud platform the idea with
cloud data proc is that we're not just
giving you yet another cluster to manage
we're actually going to let you run your
open source software
but in a way that will actually
modernize your stack at the same time we
also give you a lot of flexibility when
running data proc we expose a lot of
those knobs that you can turn now we try
to put some sane defaults on those knobs
so if you don't want to deal with them
you can get started very easily but if
you do want to start you know tuning the
knobs you have the ability to get in
there and do that but that also means
that customers are using Cloud Data proc
in a few different ways so a couple of
the common models that we see customers
using cloud data proc with is first off
what we call the job scoped cluster
model and this has been really effective
for cloud data proc customers with batch
processing and ETL workloads essentially
in this mode you can have a single
command that sends a graph of jobs to
cloud data proc we will spin up a right
sized cluster run those jobs then take
down the cluster while keeping
everything logged into stack driver and
this is really this is really easy on
Cloud Data proc really effective because
we can usually spin up a fully loaded
hadoop cluster in around 90 seconds so
when you only have about a minute and a
half overlap overhead to get yourself a
fully loaded Hadoop cluster you really
can start to think about jobs and
clusters as a single entity and we have
a lot and Cloud Data practice a lot of
features like the jobs API workflow
templates and scheduled cluster deletion
that can help with these this this model
of job scope clusters but we also have
customers that have scenarios for
long-running data proctors and some of
those situations include shared
interactive or ad hoc analysis with
web-based notebooks like Jupiter or
Zeppelin or bi dashboarding applications
based on things like Druitt and we have
a lot of features here that help as well
things like our autoscaler or our high
availability mode and if you want to
learn more I actually did a top 10 tips
for long standing data proc clusters a
couple months back
there's a webinar associated with it so
there's lots of materials out there if
you want to learn more about how to do
long standing cloud data proc clusters
but regardless of the model that you
choose our goal is to change open-source
software to be cloud native and so this
means making features that are going to
be fast easy and cost effective last
year a lone cloud data proc put launched
more than 30 features so this is still
an area that Google cloud is really
investing in and I'm calling out
cost-effective here and we actually had
some external validation that we're
building some cost-effective features we
worked with an analyst firm efg who came
back and told us that compared to an
on-premise self managed to do cluster
cloud data procs about 60% less
expensive and even compared to some of
our competitors like Amazon EMR in the
cloud space we still came in about 32%
less expensive in terms of total cost of
ownership for these cloud data proc
lustres and so cost is an obvious
optimization but most customers that are
coming to Blake and I it's not cost
that's the main driver they are really
coming to us because of a desire to make
better data-driven decisions and this is
usually the appeal of the cloud
migrations much more so than just cost
alone and the key to making that happen
is really unlocking all of the data that
is trapped in your HDFS clusters today
and so I'm actually going to do a full
section on converting HDFS to Google
Cloud storage because this is really
imperative to achieving cloud freedom
for a cluster this is what really severs
that dependency between storage and
compute now luckily this is encode in
the Hadoop code itself it's often one of
the easiest changes to make usually it's
just as simple as a prefix change but
the bottom line is that you can't really
scale HDFS because that storage is still
tied to compute so you're taking a very
pricey resource of compute and tying
yourself to a relatively inexpensive
resource of storage not only that but
you're also sily siloing
all
of your HDFS data to a single cluster
instead of exposing it to all of the
different possibilities that a cloud
provider like GCP could offer now there
are some of the reasons to still use
HDFS in the cloud especially on data
proc you might have some local storage
devices so you can do things like you
know scratch space and shuffle data or
like an L ll a P cache but the idea is
that's all pretty much temporary data
you want everything that you plan to
maintain to be written to cloud storage
and the reason why you can do this
filesystem substitution it's because
Hadoop has this abstract notion of a
filesystem and HDFS
that's just one implementation the jet
there's a java abstract class FS dot
file system and that can call into
various replacements for HDFS all
MapReduce or SPARC really care about is
getting blocks of data and so this idea
this concept it provided a lot of
advantages when HDFS was first developed
and it still does now as well as we kind
of move to the cloud and I don't have
time to deep dive on everything in this
slide there I did release an article a
couple months back if you care about
comparing cloud storage directly to HDFS
that does deep dive on a lot of this on
a lot of this and does a full comparison
but the too long didn't read version of
that is that you can pretty much replace
most air Hadoop jobs that are in HDFS
with cloud storage and that does not
mean that you pull the data from cloud
storage into HDFS it means that your
Hadoop and spark jobs can read directly
from cloud storage just as they can HDFS
over our Google Cloud storage connector
which is an open source connector for
doing just that there's also a couple
differentiators that you should be aware
of with cloud storage versus other cloud
providers so in particular our cloud
storage we're gonna get offer a strong
global consistency for a lot of those
operations that you care a lot about
with Hadoop and spark so you don't have
to be afraid to use cloud storage as a
destination if you've worked with object
stores on other cloud providers you may
have
to introduce some kludgy workaround was
I can no sequel database that sits in
the way to make up for their eventual
consistency but you don't have to do
that on Google Cloud I was working with
one customer and they said they were
trying to move to another cloud provider
for over a year and they couldn't get it
done there's too much conflicts and all
the different rights they were doing
they tried to do a POC before before
giving up they try to do a POC with us
and in three weeks they were able to get
done what they couldn't get done in a
year trying to get on another cloud
provider because of this strong
consistency in addition our renames our
metadata operations so what that means
is a lot of other cloud providers if you
were to do a Hadoop move all of the data
associated with that padieu move that's
going to actually get copied to a new
part of object store and then you're
have to wait for that to happen and then
wait for all of the old data to also get
deleted before you get a return from
your Hadoop move for us all of that
happens as a metadata operation you're
not actually going to have to move the
data around another differentiator that
we have is that across Google Cloud
Storage we're going to give you
different storage glasses for cost
optimization but you're actually going
to get a consistent API across our store
storage portfolio so you don't actually
have to change your Hadoop or spark code
as you move across these storage classes
you can get direct access to the archive
you don't have to go to a different
service wait hours for a restore and
then rerun your code you can just you
can just go even between our regional
and Nearline storage classes you can
even get the same less than a
millisecond latency on first byte reads
so in the context of Hadoop just the way
to think about our storage classes
regional storage this is what you're
going to use for your interactive high
the spark analysis or batch jobs that
might occur more than once a month next
you're going to have Nearline storage
and this is for batch jobs that are
really used for reporting or
aggregations the rule of thumb here is
data that you expect to use about no
more than once a month you'll put it in
your line and then finally code line
storage that's for your post process
data
you really don't expect to use again but
you want to keep around for either
compliance reasons or just to have it
just in case that can be moved to code
line storage rule at them on that one is
data you don't expect to use more the
touch again more than once a year and so
once you've made the shift and you're
able to move your HDFS data into cloud
storage that opens up a lot more
possibilities of things you can do with
it so if you have multiple distributions
of both Hortonworks
and cloud era on you know you're in your
environment today both of those can talk
over the GCS connector directly to cloud
storage well at the same time it opens
you up to use a lot more Google Cloud
tooling so you can start to incorporate
maybe data proc for some of your batch
processing or maybe you can start to
move some ad hoc stuff into bigquery and
access cloud storage via external tables
or even start to introduce news
streaming type applications with data
flow on top of all the same data sets
and you can be sure that everything is
you know strongly consistent so if you
want to make the move you can move an
entire petabyte of data from HDFS to
cloud storage in about three steps what
you would do is you would come into the
Google Cloud console and request a
transfer appliance your we would then
ship you a storage device it would look
something like this box on the screen
here you would put it into an NFS share
capture mode mount those NFS share NFS
shares to each of your data nodes in
your Hadoop cluster and then it's just
as simple as running the standard disk
CP Hadoop command and you'll copy all
that data over in parallel at that point
you just ship us the device back and
we'll go ahead and load that into cloud
storage for you now if you don't have a
petabyte of data that you want to move
right away but you just want to start
with some proof of concept or maybe a
data fed size that can move comfortably
across a VPN connection you can simply
install the Google Cloud Storage
connector on an existing on-prem cluster
and then copy the data over with a disk
CP I think as far as I know we're the
only cloud provider
supports not only copying of the data
over disk CP but copying of the metadata
attributes from HDFS as well so if you
don't know what I'm talking about when I
say metadata attributes what this means
is these are a file system feature that
are gonna allow user applications to
associate additional metadata for a file
or a directory oftentimes you'll see
applications do this for things like
maybe what encoding was used but when I
ran across this I was working with a
large bank and they wanted to do a full
HDFS backup keep everything encrypted as
is just you know get it copied over to
cloud storage and what they were doing
is they had an on-prem hsn.that HSM that
was storing the key locations in the
metadata attributes and so when they are
comparing cloud providers they were
looking and saying well I go to you know
these some other folks I would have to
figure out a new encryption scheme or
decrypt everything before I moved it
over but with us it was just as simple
as running that disk CP - px command the
PX stands for preserve attributes and we
were able to take all of both the HDFS
data and the metadata attributes and
they could use it as their backup but
once that data is available in Google
Cloud storage now that's going to let
you take a really hard look at your
existing hadoop cluster and see what
workloads might make sense to move to
Google Cloud a work a common workload
target I'll start with is they take an
on-prem hadoop cluster that might pretty
monolithic and sharing both ad hoc
analysis and batch reporting so they
have you know business user that are in
there and they're struggling to get
their sequel queries to run because over
the last few years people have scheduled
a bunch of jobs had a bunch of stuff in
the batch there just now piling up and
they're contending for resources so
there's an easy way to get started in
the cloud is they just start to offload
a lot of that batch stuff to Cloud Data
proc which frees up their on-prem
resources for the the business analyst
but Cloud Data proc it might not always
be the best choice depending on your
goals for instance a lot of ad hoc hive
sequel that migrates really well to a
big query our server list data warehouse
also there might be streaming
applications that fit or better with
data flow but regardless
you know of your tool or application
having that data in cloud storage that's
what's going to give you the freedom to
modernize your environment and actually
start to pick the right tool for the job
instead of just being limited to the
tools and the compute resources that are
on that single HDFS storage cluster now
we aren't doing this alone we have a lot
of partners in this space that can help
we are partnered with all the
traditional Hadoop vendors to help you
with data processing we have partners
that can help with data ingestion and
movement and service partners that can
actually be your hands on keyboard to
actually get you migrated in addition we
have some new partnerships for some
niche solution providers that can bring
a unified kind of experience to Hadoop
and spark and you're gonna hear more
about that in our data analytics keynote
tomorrow but you know like I said the
big three on Prem Hadoop platforms in
this space they all support the GCS
connector today so you can move your
data between HDFS and cloud storage or
you could even process cloud storage
data directly from these platforms we're
also partnered with folks like
informatica among others who can support
very complex enterprise data workflows
and they can they really help because
they integrate deeply with GCP services
but also your on-prem scheduling systems
today and finally again we have
migration partners that actually can you
know get this stuff moved we have a lot
longer list than just these but these
are the partners that we know that at
least I know have a lot of proof points
for successfully migrating customers
from on Prem Hadoop to GCP relatively
quickly so with this I'm gonna hand this
off to Blake who's gonna talk of gave
him some first-hand experience on how
he's actually my gur did some really
massive hadoop footbridge to the cloud
thanks Chris
hi everyone so first we're going to talk
about some reference cases we send to
see a few ber patterns that people
follow in their move to Google cloud
platform in terms of Hadoop in spark and
we're going to tell that's through a
couple
customer stories so first off with with
the uber patterns we tend to see three
primary use cases so the first is lift
and shift these are customers that are
looking to move lift and move to GCP
because they're having pain around you
know scaling elasticity globalization
etc and they sometimes want to move very
quickly and sometimes they want to move
without risk that can drive them to kind
of to lift in shift pattern sometimes
customers will decouple storage and
compute and sometimes they will not and
we'll talk a little bit about that
waiter the customer example we're gonna
go over today is Twitter which started
their Google cloud platform journey
about a year ago and has quite a few
talks here at necks 19 and you know the
kind of partner technologies we kind of
run into in this case are things like
on-premises who dupe distributions
clutter horn works
map are as well as customers that use
Apache big-top and customize themselves
the key GCP services that are used are
GCE Google compute engine for raw
compute as well as Google Cloud storage
that we kind of went over today next is
lifting we architected were modernize
you know these are customers that are
they want to kind of alleviate more than
just they want to realize more than just
the decoupling of storage and computer
the elasticity of the cloud they want to
reduce operational overhead they want
auto scaling they want to just pay for
the resources that they need use things
like auto scaling and etc by using kind
of dynamic and ephemeral clusters kind
of like Chris was telling earlier with
the pattern we're gonna go over a great
customer example 3 p.m. solutions and
the key services are used here on top of
the two that we already discussed data
proc for a managed to do can spark
environment as well as composer
which is our managed apache airflow next
is transformed accomodative so you know
customers that are looking to kind of
really transform how they're they're
doing batch stream processing and adopt
kind of like cloud native products you
know these are these are customers are
usually operating at the high end of the
the data scale they're they're looking
for advanced things around object
lifecycle management
they're looking to kind of streamline
their batch and streaming pipelines by
using a unified analytical engine which
we'll go into a little bit earlier and
on top of just using the technologies
that we kind of talked to you today
they're also doing things like you know
ml engine or bigquery they're doing ml
or or bigquery and I guess I guess one
last point here is that this is not
necessarily a sequential journey you
know some customers target
lift and shift and then you know not
only do they they migrate to lifting
architects or transform cloud native but
because some customers kind of make that
jump immediately to cloud native so it
you know your journey is dependent upon
you know the time the the risk poor risk
profile and a lot of other factors and
you know Google cloud can help you make
the right choice so the first pattern
we're gonna kind of go into is kind of
lift and shift so we see here is that
you know customers typically have a
monolithic to do cluster that's running
on premises you know we're co-locating
storage and compute and you know across
an interconnect or a VPN we are moving
data using DCP or in some cases the
transfer appliance that Chris talked
about earlier into Google Cloud Storage
that Google Cloud Storage can be used in
one of two ways for clusters that are
being spun up with the goal of being
decoupled from their storage the compute
is created in GCE
with the distribution of your choice
edge nodes are added with the tools of
your choice things like Jupiter lab
Zeppelin etc and they directly used the
GCS connector and the GC GS prefix to
access the data in cloud storage for
four clusters that are also hosting data
in you know on the GCE VMs local disk
for HDFS customers are looking to use
tools such as Impala which has limited
connectivity to to Google auth storage
at this time we'll then saturate the
data in HDFS from Google Cloud storage
so a customer that is kind of doing this
very very successfully we have a lot of
customers actually doing this
successfully as a starting point and
moving into the cloud but you know one
of the largest is Twitter so you know
Twitter has currently on premises in
their various to do clusters around half
a million cores of Hadoop some of these
clusters are as large as 12,500 nodes
there's under 300 petabytes of data
under management and you know the
systems process you know over one
trillion messages per day the breakdown
of the workloads is kind of seen on top
part in part in the image clashing
colors but you know we see that you know
processing and production batch
processing I'm using scouting is about
30% real-time production processing is
about 60% using quite a few tools and ad
hoc processing and tools like presto and
hive is about is about 10% you know
Twitter is being is actually quite vocal
with their journey to the cloud and you
know they're they're continuing that
trend by presenting multiple talks at
Google next 2019 so we see here is a
couple of talks they kind of primarily
break down into you know how is Twitter
migrating that much data into GCP so if
you're interested in understanding how
you know large their interconnects are
how they use DCP how they verify the
integrity of the data etc the first talk
is a great one for you if you're under
if you're looking to understand how
Twitter understands and implements
object lifecycle management policies in
Google Cloud and basically extends their
on-premises custom tooling that they do
they do open source that last talk on
what the architecture is for data
storage of GCS and how you know user
identity management comes into play
great sessions so the second talk is I
mean sorry the second pattern is liftin
we architect re architecture or
modernize and so now we're getting into
some of the things that you know Chris
Illustrated the data POC is very capable
of doing you know what we see here is
you know that you know customers once
again our moving data into Google Cloud
Storage either via transfer appliance or
DCP but
and you know it's really unlocking the
ability for us to bring very very
defined resources to bear on that data
and that the you know GCS provides near
unlimited ingress and egress bandwidth
to basically support all these
analytical engines using it at the same
time and so here on the Left we see
cloud Composer or manage Apache airflow
spinning up job scope clusters this is
traditionally done for badger ETL
processes you can do things like
understand how much data you have to ETL
and dynamically assign a cluster with X
amount of nodes spin that up perform the
ETL or batch process and then tear it
down you're only paying for exactly what
you use and at the end you're kind of
persisting that that analytical resort
result back to Google Cloud Storage you
know on the right-hand side we see semi
long-lived clusters so this aids in
quite a few things what you see he'll
here Illustrated is kind of a red black
or blue green kind of deployment where
we have version 1.1 of our our Hadoop
image running but we're also running a
canary for a newer version of our of our
platform Wow
you know you used to be very hard to you
know upgrade and test a new cluster on
premises like a huge monolithic cluster
like being elastic in the crowd the
ability to spin up new clusters and
basically load balance between them is
you know makes that a lot easier and
then what we also see here is that we
can build up we can build clusters for
that are purpose-built we can have
clusters that are that are built to run
HBase Druid presto a spark streaming etc
any any use case that requires long
living clusters you know on top of that
data proc has native integration into
clout logging and Google stack driver
and so you get metrics that the cluster
can use to auto scale you get metrics
that help you understand the health of
your jobs and what's going on through
great Operations tools and then lastly
it becomes very easy to take things like
Jupiter lab hosted in cloud
lab or Jew per lab hosted in Google
cloud machine learning environment and
pointed at your data proc clusters and
use them as an analytical back-end and
so we have three PM solutions so three
PM is basically a solution provider that
basically pulls in customer reviews and
customer listings from Amazon eBay and
walmart.com on a daily basis and helps
sellers as well as these retail
organizations like understand when you
know not understand that the signal from
that data and whether or not some
product listings are fraudulent and we
they originally had this solution
on-premises and it was just unable to
scale due to peaks and peaks in demand
during events like a very busy four
quarter retail fourth-quarter retail so
what they were trying to do is they they
basically moved it to the cloud they
wanted to spin up clusters for exactly
what they needed they wanted to run
large amounts of they wanted to run with
a hundreds hundreds of nodes to
basically complete this in a very tight
SLA of about four hours so what they
were able to do is analyze over 160
million customer reviews ETL that and
put that into an HBase cluster and make
that available for their for their end
users and what's really kind of amazing
here is like when they built the
solution when it was operating at a much
lower scale that solution just kind of
scaled with them so that the CI CD and
the solution etc basically scaled with
their business and so they didn't need
any additional Hadoop administrators to
kind of scale that solution has their
business scale
lastly we have come to listen to lift
and transform pattern and this is kind
of you know it's aptly named like
lifting cloud native this is kind of
getting the best and greatest out of
Google cloud platform and so with this
but this is really kind of trying to
show is that there's many ingestion
methods whether it be Apache Kafka or
pub/sub or external providers such as
double-click YouTube Adobe analytics etc
you know moving data into Google Cloud
Storage BigTable etc via many analytical
engines we can then bring any any type
of analytics on top of that bigquery
data flow data proc and start doing
machine learning analysis on that data
to support that those use cases and then
just integrating with any bi or
visualization tool almost any that's in
the market today as well as Google Cloud
Data studio this is kind of the lifting
cloud native a couple points here since
they're kind of new you know customers I
tend to lifting cloud native tend to do
things like a adopt Google Cloud
dataflow due to its kind of unified
batch and stream engine right so with
with very little modification you can
run pipelines both in batch and
streaming while in the Hadoop world that
was were traditionally done in like
different analytical engines you know
customers start to adopt bigquery we we
see patterns where customers will
continue to do ETL in hive or pig in
Hadoop but then look to do interactive
query in query and then lastly we start
to see customers that go cloud native
really go all-in in machine learning
right so you know as customers become
you know adept at processing data
managing its lifecycle increasing its
discoverability through other tools to
its end-users we we really see that in a
lot of cases queries per user in a
company double six to eight months six
to nine months after like a large-scale
adoption is like GCP and so we start to
see machine learning kind of intro
picture and the company I want to
highlight here is Pandora so we've been
working with Hendo for over the last six
months you know Pandora had quite a
large on-premises hoodoos footprint of
over 2,700 nodes seven petabytes of data
and you know internal analysts basically
participated in the creation of like
over a 120,000 hive tables and the ruie
drove like all different corners of
their business and so if you're looking
to understand how you know Pandora you
know is making this migration and some
of the decisions that they made along
the way there's a talk tomorrow
afternoon
in the Palace Hotel as well that talks
about how they move their on-premise
analytics and interactive query to data
proc in bigquery and then there's also a
talk on Thursday morning on composing
Pandora's move to DCP which really kind
of illustrates a journey from moving
from on-premises Apache air flow to
Google Cloud Composer for a more managed
experience and so we've reached the
point where we you know understand the
tools are available within GCP we
understand some of the common patterns
that people take and so how do you start
your own migration how do you start your
own journey so first off it was in quite
mentioned but I'm part of Google's
professional services organization
Google goes above and beyond to in our
customer assess about in our customer
set with customer success right so we
have a very unconventional professional
services organization that's not a
profit center that looks to meet their
customer where they where they are
develops you know methods and processes
on the fly with our customers to
basically target achieve whatever lift
and shift patterns they've they've
chosen right and we do that while hoping
you get the most out of your Google
Cloud products and we often work with
partners that you know kind of Chris
talked to earlier partners that have
specific expertise and who do migrations
to
we execute this work so Google cloud
Professional Services has a data
analytics practice within it that has
migrated dozens of customers from
on-premises and other public cloud
providers to GCP through every single
one of the patterns I discussed earlier
today and we commonly create artifacts
that we don't like retires via solutions
on our on our website blog posts on the
Google cloud data blog as well as
various articles on medium so we kind of
have you know over the dozens of
migrations that we've actually performed
and kind of come up with an opinionated
methodology for moving customers whether
it's lift and shift to lift in your
architect or lift and cloud native it's
kind of broken down into two major
themes the first is the plan and that is
comprised of four discrete steps and the
next is the deploy which is six so what
typically happens is over the course of
a few weeks
you know we lead discovery workshops
where we not only understand our
customers environment but we also
educate them on the the really that the
ins and outs of the gcpd data stack at a
very very low level we work with them to
determine end state an end state that's
not only a social architecture but also
organizational changes that are required
as well and and in other ancillary
things next we work with with with
customers to prioritize their workloads
and actually deep dive into their data
sets and then actually design the
migration path and plan so that kind of
wraps up the planning phase moving into
deployment we typically see customers
amelie start to move data to GCS when
this is typically done over an
interconnect or a VPN connection there's
usually a long tail effort to this this
this type of activity and so we kind of
get that kicked off like pretty quick
next is we do
deployment of the big data stack so we
understand which components are required
within the Hadoop ecosystem and we work
to build an environment that is
optimized for those components and
working and end
next comes moving the workloads right so
we actually work to move every single
workload test and validate it and at the
same time integrate with other GCP
services like stack driver logging
composer for orchestration bigquery etc
right and at the end
Google has you know cloud CRE and sre
processes that kind of help run the
system and make sure that there's
production operation readiness so this
is I just want to you know cap off there
this planning your migration section
with a sample Hadoop migration timeline
this is customized you know for every
customer for every use case and these
this is kind of typically the high level
activities that we kind of see with the
the objectives that we try to reach you
know so first off like we have analysis
kickoff and we understand the
architectural the architecture of the
entire platform and try to implement
foundational things so you know we only
find that you know two implements a big
data and analytic solution we must be
must be operating on kind of a firm
bedrock foundation and those are things
like infrastructure setup so you know
it's very important for us to ensure
that there's a correct Network design
that there is logging that there you
know et cetera is in place you know kind
of you know flipping the the hudu
migration on the previous side in
another direction we see here we talk
about the data migration GCS
configuration understanding things like
object lifecycle management
identity and access management how not
only are you going to have that first
initial sync of data into GCP but how
you're going to enable the continuous
delivery of data that you may be
generating on-premises so all these
things are kind of taken into account
and processes are created automation is
is created to to handle that we find
that
it's all about getting that first
cluster up and going kind of defining
that data platform because once you
define it once you can spin it at
multiple times and we tend to see two
kind of parallel threads where there's
kind of the migration of existing
workloads you know after this this this
first cluster has been created and then
at the same time other business groups
within a customer will start using this
new data platform to kind of bring new
use cases online and then lastly there's
kind of the goal I'd preparedness right
so bringing that production operational
readiness through SLA is SL o--'s etc
and then for going live and then we kind
of rinse and repeat so this is an
iterator iterative process so with that
I want to point you to a few resources
that you can basically seek out to
understand you know how do I make this
real for me right so the first article
is migrating on-premises who do
infrastructure to Google cloud platform
this really goes into the technical
details of moving data into GCS as well
as understanding what pattern is right
for you
lift and chip flips right we architect
flipped and cloud native and what it's
like to create jobs in workflows etc
right and last I would like to encourage
you to follow with your favorite RSS
reader our data analytics cloud blog you
know Chris mentioned some of the
articles that he's created there's a lot
of great Googlers who do the same and
you'll hear interesting product
announcements as well and so that's plug
google.com slash blog slash products
data analytics
[Music]